what's up everybody
jared here today we're talking about
everyone's favorite movie with puppet
sex
team america world police the film which
creators matt stone and trey parker
imagined as a jerry bruckheimer flick
with puppets
raised plenty of eyebrows when it was
released though reviews were generally
positive
it lampoons both mainstream american
conservatism
and liberalism we must take radical
action against the fascists
in our own country during the iraq war
and the war on terror
there's no denying that 15 years later
the film is still
very very funny but as political satire
it's worth asking
is it smart political satire or just an
excuse to sing about how bad the film
pearl harbor is
i miss you more than michael bay missed
the mark when he made
pearl harbor let's find out in this
wisecrack edition on team
america world police deep or dumb
and as everybody knows spoilers ahead
alright guys let's do a quick recap
gary johnston is just your average stage
actor performing in a musical about aids
that is until a man named spotswood
recruits him to join an elite military
squad devoted to fighting terrorists
that squad team america travels the
globe trying to stop
extremists armed with weapons of mass
destruction while leaving a trail of
destruction in their wake
[Music]
their actions are protested by the likes
of sean penn alec baldwin and other
famous hollywood actors in the
film actors guild gary must use his
acting skills to infiltrate a terrorist
cell
and prevent an attack even worse than
911 from what intelligence has gathered
it would be nine eleven times a hundred
nine eleven times a hundred jesus that's
yes 91 100.
one that is actually being masterminded
by kim jong-il
before we get into the merits of the
film it's important to understand its
historical context
team america was released a mere year
and a half after the us invasion of iraq
in 2003
in the lead-up to the invasion president
george w bush used the phrase axis of
evil during his january 2002 state of
the union address
to describe the governments of north
korea iran and iraq these regimes bush
alleged exported terror and actively
sought weapons of mass destruction
which posed a danger to america in the
wake of 9 11.
much of this context shines in specific
jokes
france who was heavily criticized for
not joining the american coalition to
invade iraq
is the first victim of a terrorist
attack hans blix a
real-life weapons inspector who found no
evidence of chemical weapons in iraq
finds himself threatened by kim jong-il
before being eaten by sharks the film's
preoccupation with wmds
spoke to ongoing fears of attacks by
terrorists or foreign governments
with nuclear weapons dirty bombs or
chemical weapons put down the weapon of
mass destruction
and get on the ground now there are two
main ideas we're going to cover today
how the film satirizes american foreign
policy and how the film satirizes actors
protesting that foreign policy
so let's get into the first american
foreign policy during the bush era the
basic tension of the film was summarized
by a new
york times article in 2004. matt stone
and trey parker hate the war in iraq
however they suspected
it might be necessary the very title
team america world police is a jab at
neoconservatism
a political ideology prominent in the
bush administration
that promoted american intervention
globally to promote peace and democracy
in other words if you were a dictator
not living up to the usfa's standards on
human rights
the old red white and blue had some
cruise missiles with your name on them
or more simply
for neoconservatives dictators like
saddam hussein or kim jong-il
were prime targets for regime change of
course the idea that america should go
around saving the world has
one big shortcoming americans themselves
much of the film's subtext suggests that
when it comes to world affairs
americans are self-centered dunces when
the film cuts to establishing shots of
france
egypt panama or north korea each
location is marked in relation to its
distance from america
as in it's the center of the world while
paris france follows the standard for
denoting a city followed by its country
places like cairo and the panama canal
are described as being in
the middle east or central america the
joke being that americans can't be
bothered to learn where a place is
aside from its vague geographic area and
if they do know
well they need to show it cairo that's
in egypt
each foreign location also comes adorned
with lazy stereotyping
france's streets are made of croissants
while the people spout stereotypical
phrases like
meanwhile in cairo terrorists repeat
nonsense words like
durka mixed with muhammad and jihad
[Music]
later the people of panama are depicted
carrying around weed
playing steel drums and screaming
as they're swept up in a flood and kim
jong-il's palace is surrounded by
menacing mountains and an ominous red
glow
befitting for a member of bush's axis of
evil oh and also
some of the buildings are just chinese
takeout boxes this
general ignorance informs most of team
america's actions
as spotswood admits he thought the
terrorist mastermind would be middle
eastern
not asian kim jong-il why is he helping
terrorists
when gary undergoes a state-of-the-art
surgery to blend in with egyptians
he's essentially given patchy pubes and
brown face
also he wears a towel on his head in
lieu of a turban
so there's that more importantly team
america in the name of saving the world
causes wanton destruction everywhere
they go
damn i missed him after seeing team
america triumphantly declare victory
over terrorism amidst the chaos they
have just wrought
the question is clear are we the baddies
the term blowback is a term coined by
the cia in a 1953 memo that described
the possible unintended effects
of their covert operation to overthrow
the iranian government
that memo would become prescient after
the cia staged a coup to solidify the
iranian monarch's power another
revolution would depose him more than 20
years later
this time with an open hostility to
america and their role in supporting the
shah
blowback was an increasingly relevant
topic during the war on terror
especially as people wondered if growing
up in a war zone might make one
predisposed to recruitment into an
anti-american terrorist organization
it's a connection team america
explicitly draws with scenes like this
we have put out a jihad on the infidels
because they destroyed our lives or
as the team casually destroys some
merchants livelihood when they land
author and professor chalmers johnson
argued our military interventions to
stop terrorism
would only create more desperate and
embittered childless parents and
parentless children
and so recruit more maddened people to
the terrorist cause
what you're doing here is creating a
mexican joker
but as much as the film seems to
understand blowback things get a little
muddled with its crowning idea
the philosophy of dicks oopsies and
a-holes
first heard from a drunk guy in a bar
gary recites this wisdom at the climax
of the film
it goes something like this there are
three kinds of people
dicks who just want to [ __ ] everything
[ __ ] who want everyone to get along
and holes who just [ __ ] on everyone seas
don't like dicks because they get [ __ ]
by dicks but dicks also [ __ ]
holes which is why [ __ ] should be
grateful for
the message is dictators like kim
jong-il or saddam hussein are
holes [ __ ] on the world oppressing
their citizens and posing a threat to
everyone around them
american interventionists are the juiced
up blowhards listening to toby keith
thinking they can bomb their problems
into oblivion and everyone protesting
the dicks are the [ __ ]
bleeding heart liberals who naively
think that being nice can stop terrorism
importantly gary realizes that sometimes
dick's too hard
and it takes a [ __ ] to show him that
and thus there is a kind of
functionalist balance to american
society
where take care of hostile a-holes while
[ __ ] complain loud enough to stop
their worst excesses
parker and stone are more or less
reiterating the message behind south
park's 100th episode i'm a little bit
country
in it the townsfolk realized the secret
to american success
is having half of its citizens
aggressively advocating for war
while the other half aggressively
protest war the strength of this country
is the ability to do one thing and say
another in this way america can be the
world's police
while pretending they don't want to be
of course the sentiment is somewhat
nonsensical
as even the show admits let the flag for
hypocrisy
i hate this town i really really do it
seems then that the film is arguing for
the status quo
or at least comically justifying it and
if you're like most americans you
probably agree the status quo is itself
the real
whole [ __ ] on us all the best
correlate to what we're going to call
the dap philosophy
is political realism it stresses that in
international relations
pretty much everyone is a dick and a
state should focus on its own
self-interest when interacting with
other nations
while there are a few different ways to
theorize the international realm
a competing theory to realism is
liberalism
which focuses on how international
actors often come together to cooperate
so [ __ ] in the parlance of team
america team america suggests that the
ideal solution is somewhere in between
where the machiavellian actions of
realists are reigned in by a counter
philosophy
it gets tricky when we enter into act
holes because
souls are more or less indistinguishable
from dicks
just as want to [ __ ] everyone [ __ ]
want to sh on everyone
so what differentiates king from
[ __ ]
is being a slightly more benevolent form
of thing
is it if they're the aforementioned axis
of evil they [ __ ]
and as the film previously suggested
aren't the just spawning
more [ __ ] what if their incessant
[ __ ] just creates isis which was
formed by
a guy who became powerful only after
colin powell said he was a prime target
of the us
iraq today harbors a deadly terrorist
network headed by
abu musab al-zakawi will any level of
king spawn more
holes or just [ __ ] too hard so on
foreign policy the movie points to some
real criticisms
properly dunking on everyone but it
doesn't offer a clear solution
so much as it suggests we're all idiots
so
kinda deep but let's get to the other
criticism celebrities
aside from us interventionism team
america's second satirical target
is the people who protested it
specifically actors
celebrities like sean pan and janine
garofalo regularly appeared on cable
news to debate the merits of the war
in an interview with 60 minutes parker
and stone complained that the opinions
of famous people crowded out the
opinions of
actual experts on the news when sean
penn is on tv on cnn
during the before the iraq war talking
about the nuclear nonproliferation
treaty super funny
that is that is pure comet gold the
question is what about acting makes
someone uniquely qualified to
as sean penn did comment on the treaty
of the non-proliferation of nuclear
weapons
or why did janine graflow get to appear
on fox news
only to recycle an argument she read in
a paper as
actors it is our responsibility to read
the newspapers
and then say what we read on television
like it's our own opinion
this critique is all over the film both
overtly and
more subtly the film actors guild thinks
they know how to achieve world peace
even their deliberations visually evoke
the united nations
gary's unique qualifications for team
america rely on a fantasy in which
acting is some
superpower in the war on terror like it
or not
you're the one with the power to do
something the cutting edge technology
that allows him to infiltrate the
terrorist organization
is none other than bad plastic surgery a
specialty among hollywood's elite okay
so on a basic level it's an apt jab at
major news networks who put celebrities
on tv
to comment on serious matters for no
other reason than they're famous
as stone told the new york times an
actor convinces himself he's doing
something important to the world
you're an actor all you do is read lines
also embedded into their
characterization of celebrities is an
air of what i'll call smelling your own
farts
perhaps nobody embodies the spirit of
deeply inhaling one's fecal tinged
expulsions
more than sean penn i look back and i
didn't work hard enough
to keep this admin you know as one
individual to keep this administration
from taking power
his argument is that his status enables
him to spread important information that
people would otherwise ignore
which might be true but this is also
from the guy that allegedly hired a
photographer to follow him around while
he saved people in haiti
and whether you agree or disagree with
him he often echoes points made by more
qualified experts for some actors it
seemed their prominence made them
qualified to reshape the world in their
image
a sentiment the film takes to task
puppet pen brags about how
he visited iraq and only saw flowery
meadows and gumdrop smiles
last year i went to iraq before team
america showed up it was a happy place
they had flowery meadows and rainbow
skies and and rivers made of chocolate
where the children
danced and laughed and played with
gumdrop smiles a joke rooted in the fact
that the real pen
did prior to the invasion travel to iraq
he commented on how kind the people he
met were the iraqi people
are you know as warm as
people get but the flowery meadows line
is a bit of a mischaracterization of his
real opinions
penn was also quick to call saddam
hussein a monster
and talk about the horrible conditions
the citizens of iraq were living in due
to
international sanctions so the idea that
people like penn were [ __ ] who were
unable or unwilling to admit how shitty
the situation in iraq was
seems a little off base now there might
be a deeper philosophy here
one argued by our favorite dan harmon
look-alike slavoy zizek
jija criticizes the left for predicating
their support for people like refugees
on their alleged angelic nature that we
should welcome them because they are all
perfect wholesome humans but for zheck
going through the kind of horrific
tragedies that cause people to seek
asylum
does not make them morally elevated
they're just as flawed as everybody
else it's not that he thinks we
shouldn't welcome them but that one's
access to basic human rights
shouldn't be predicated on being the
perfect victim
now maybe stone and parker were trying
to suggest that hollywood liberals
similarly see figures like kim jong-il
or saddam hussein
as victims of u.s aggression and thus
are morally elevated but for the most
part
nobody was really defending these people
even garofalo thought that hussein
should be disarmed in that fox news
interview
so maybe not the most apt criticism but
what about celebrities dominating news
coverage
a point i'm hugely sympathetic to now if
the message is that celebrities
shouldn't have opinions it's probably
not a sentiment most people agree with
as divisive as this issue could seem
most americans would agree with
blitzchang's right to voice his support
of the hong kong protests and many will
also agree lebron james is within his
rights to seem like a complete idiot on
the same topic
so many people could have been harmed
not only financially but physically
emotionally spiritually in other words a
celebrity's opinion should be judged on
the merit of that opinion
not who it's coming from and more to the
point does this also mean that stone and
parker
themselves famous for making a cartoon
about potty-mouthed kids
aren't entitled to an opinion this
becomes especially awkward when you
consider that a large swath of south
park episodes
are thinly veiled metaphors for their
opinions they even inadvertently created
a movement called
south park republicans then again
they're not showing up on news networks
to spout their opinions
if they want to ask what do celebrities
know about foreign policy
we can certainly ask that of them and
their dap philosophy but we won't
because we'd rather take the argument on
its face
but they're not entirely wrong either
because cable news is
trash it's no secret that networks like
cnn and fox would rather put up a
spectacle with a good heal than report
anything objectively but if the argument
is fox and cnn have more credible
experts like political scientists and
journalists
that argument also has its shortcomings
cable news has become a breeding ground
for political insiders and other
alleged experts who in academic parlance
are
full of but even in the context of the
iraq war there was a huge
failure of media organizations and their
experts to properly vet the
administration's motives for going to
war
so if parker and stone just wanted to
see what the real experts had to say
those experts wouldn't have saved them
at least not the smooth-talking ones who
would be selected by cable news in the
first place
and then there's the unfortunate fact
that people just care more about what
celebrities say
even if we shouldn't so yes you can go
to poli-sci professor.blogspot.com
but you won't so where do we land on the
topic of american foreign policy the
film is kind of deep
but not overly and infallibly deep
because some things just don't add up
and while the celebrity shtick tugs at
my heartstrings
i have to give it a shrug funny sure
deep
not quite but not dumb either so team
america gets a wisecrack certified kinda
deep but
funny as hell
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and catch y'all next time
peace
[Music]
you